welcome back this week is all about
raising awareness for poison prevention
Rocky spoke to Southwest Medical part of
Optum the sponsors of this segment to
learn more about the perks
this is a really unique topic it is
poison prevention awareness week March
19th through the 25th so just explain
um the risk that you're seeing out there
with poison and why we need to have this
type of week
so poison can mean so many different
things it's not just what we think of
like drinking cleaning chemicals or
something like that kids can get into
vitamins which can if taken into too
many amounts can be overdose Tylenol
medicines they get into everything so
poison can mean many things and that's
why it's so important to bring this to
light and have a special week of
awareness for it because it's not just
what we usually think of when it comes
to cleaning chemicals it can be anything
when do poisonings happen the most when
should we be most aware
believe it or not ninety percent of
poisons occur in the home so that's the
number one environment what should we do
in a poison emergency
so there's a couple different things you
can do and different poisons require
different treatments so anytime a child
is unconscious not breathing having
seizures or convulsing call 9-1-1
immediately but for liquid poisonings or
substances that are swallowed If the
child still has any liquid in their
mouth they should vomit it out or spit
it out but you don't want to make them
vomit if they've already swallowed it so
um or you know syrup of ipicac is also
not recommended to use because it
elicits a vomiting response but if
there's liquid still in the mouth they
should spit it out for fumes that are
inhaled you want to get the child
outside into fresh air immediately and
then you know we already talked about
some things that we don't think are
poison well batteries are a perfect
example especially those small cylinder
like batteries so those small circular
batteries if they're swallowed which is
common that elicits an emergency room
visit immediately due to the caustic
nature of the batteries what steps
should parents take to maybe avoid these
situations child proof child proof I
cannot say it enough
um as weird as it sounds it's even a
good idea to get down on your hands and
knees and literally get a child's eye
view of hey what can I get into simple
things like outlet covers cabinet locks
door handle locks which can sometimes be
adult proof that they work so well
adults can't use them those are things
that should be put into place those
cleaning chemicals that we talked about
medicines should be put up high Out Of
Reach Out of Sight maybe even in a
locked cabinet as well
parents should know the age-appropriate
CPR and heimlich Maneuvers and another
good idea especially with poison week is
having the Poison Control Center phone
number posted somewhere in the home on
the refrigerator
um in you know plain sight that way for
parents or any babysitters that are
watching the child it is immediately
available for use in an event an
emergency
thank you to Southwest Medical part of
Optum for sponsoring this segment you
can give them a call at
702-877-5199 or visit
s-malv.com forward slash en forward
slash we'll be right back
[Music]